let's upload a photo to Google Cloud  storage from rails I've already created  a bucket so the first thing we need to  do is create a cloud storage access key  so we can write to our bucket we can do  this by opening the cloud storage  interoperability settings and clicking  create a new key then using the carrier  wave gem will create an initializer file  and add the cloud storage credentials we  just generated to it in our controller's  create action we can now save our photo  to cloud storage using the G cloud  rubygem to do this we'll initialize G  cloud for our app tell G cloud which  bucket we'd like to upload the photo to  and pass it the local file URL we get  from carrier wave we can also optionally  specify the file name of the photo in  cloud storage as a second parameter  we'll save the file in cloud storage as  the current timestamp now when we start  our rail server and add a new cat photo  we can see it saved to our bucket